hi hi
when you play something like the sims
the player is actually the one building
the rule set
i'm giving the player a toy and the
player is turning it into a game
it's almost magical
as a designer you're actually dealing
with two computers
first the electronic one sitting on the
table in front of you but more
importantly
the player's imagination the player's
brains
[Music]
being a game designer turned into a
lifelong learning process where i can go
off in any subject i want to
and it's tax deductible
i'm going to expose you to a number of
fundamental concepts about game design
i want to dive deep into the psychology
of the player the mental modeling that
goes on
how to build emergence surprise and to
try to predict
what's going to motivate players and
pull them in you can take almost
anything and make it a fascinating
interactive experience
you watch somebody play a game most of
what they're doing is failing you need
to design the game such that failure
is interesting and understandable so you
go back and say aha
[Music]
oh jeez this is actually kind of fun
[Music]
good
and films have a very different
emotional palette film is totally based
upon empathy you know you can look at
characters
and they're happy we feel happy the kind
of emotions that we can actually get out
of games
are very different things like
guilt or pride teamwork a lot of that is
based upon
agency as soon as you take that away
from the players it's kind of like being
in a movie theater where also the screen
goes black
that's what it's like when you take the
control away from a player
a generation that's creating games now
has so many opportunities
you're having a vision for something
that's going to go out and change people
so find something you're passionate
about and start exploring
i'm will wright and this is a simulation
a
simulation
of my master class
you